we've done tons of user testing on this
and it turns out it doesn't work and
after an extended period of time your
arm wants to fall off
it doesn't work it's ergonomically
terrible Steve Jobs must be rolling in
his grave because right now Apple has
teams working on touch screen Max for
the first time ever but it's not what
you think because I've been doing a
bunch of research and I found out what
they're working on and it seems like it
might not even be what you think this
should be so let's get right into it
this leak came from Mark German the most
accurate Apple leaker out there saying
that apple is working on his first max
with touch screens in a major reversal
the company has teams working on a new
Macbook Pro with a touch screen for
release in 2025 but the story gets a
little bit more complicated than this of
course Steve Jobs would not be happy
because he did say that using
touchscreen laptops is ergonomically
terrible your arm's gonna get tired and
that's why Apple hasn't done it in so
long now Ming shakuo who's also another
good apple leak speaker leaked that
there's going to be an OLED MacBook Pro
coming as early as next year and
apparently that could be the one that's
supposed to come with the touchscreen
now in my personal opinion I cannot
stand touchscreen laptops like the Dell
XPS three in one I just never got used
to it I don't like it you get
fingerprints on the screen and there's
even other legit downsides like
reflectivity of the display getting
worse because of adding the touch screen
layer so I never wanted it but I guess
apple is working on it and I'm not the
only one because there are other Twitter
users who are saying the same thing I've
still yet to even once in my life wish
my Mac had a touch screen and I actually
agree but here's the tweet that really
got me thinking Apple definitely isn't
working on touch screen Max not only did
Apple explain how touchscreen Maps make
no sense and they're an ergonomic
nightmare but then the iPad would pretty
much be a useless product and I somewhat
agree because if your MacBook can be a
touch screen then there are fewer
reasons to buy an iPad or if your iPad
can legit run Mac OS then why would you
buy a Mac and Apple has actually
addressed the merging of the iPad and
Mac issue before and guess what Greg
joswiak said there's two conflicting
stories people like to tell about the
iPad and Mac on one hand people say that
they are in conflict with each other
that somebody has to decide whether they
want a Mac or they want an iPad or
people say that we're merging them into
one then there's this really Grand
conspiracy we have to eliminate the two
categories and make them one the reality
is that neither is true we're quite
proud of the fact that we work really
really hard to create the best products
in their respective category so
basically Apple for many years has been
keeping the core design and feature set
different between those two categories
of products so that people are forced to
buy both a Mac and an IP pad and here's
the better part about that if a customer
buys both a Mac and an iPad then
eventually each product will need to get
replaced and that leads to more sales
for Apple so it makes sense for Apple to
kind of separate those two product
categories but here's where things get a
little bit different due to this tweet
from Parker ordolani touch screens on
laptops make no sense to me if they're
not convertible so that begs another
question so what if it's actually not a
Macbook at all what if it is an iPad
like this person on Twitter said please
let this be an iPad with a magic
keyboard form factor and that is exactly
what I think it's going to be an iPad
Pro that can essentially some way switch
to using a form of Mac OS and it's not
just me saying that because we actually
have patents and leaks so let's get
right into it last year in May there was
a new Apple patent that described an
iPad keyboard accessory that triggers a
Mac OS like UI so essentially you grab
your iPad Pro you put it onto your magic
keyboard it detects it and it switches
to this different Mac OS like UI and if
that sounds familiar it should because
that's essentially exactly what we have
with Samsung's decks where you open up a
different app and it becomes a more
desktop like computer UI and if I open
up this actual pattern you can see
images here where you connect the iPad
to the accessory which is like a magic
keyboard and you see this Mac OS like UI
right here but there's also an apple
pencil connected which points to it
actually being an iPad and here you can
see the images right here this is
clearly in Mac OS like UI so the idea
here is that it's not a convertible
MacBook but an iPad Pro that switches to
this software when you connect it to a
keyboard and that is actually a great
idea because you're gonna force people
to buy buy a magic keyboard which is
very expensive to be able to use this
and that is going to help sell more iPad
pros and expensive accessories so it's a
win-win for Apple but here is the catch
they're not actually going to give you
full on Mac OS because we have this leak
from Majin Buu on Twitter according to
my source Apple could be testing a
smaller version of Mac OS exclusively
for the new iPad Pro M2 which might
actually be the M3 if that comes out
later Mendocino should be the code name
for Mac OS 14 a simplified version
should be planned for the M2 so
basically Apple isn't merging Mac OS
into the iPad Pro it's not getting full
on Mac OS it's getting basically a
simplified version of it so even with
this new product that's kind of hybrid
with iPad OS and Mac OS it's still not
going to replace a Macbook entirely so
since you won't get full Mac OS but of
course it's going to be better than iPad
OS is right now so Apple isn't going to
completely butcher the Mac by giving
full Mac OS to the iPad imagine boot
even gave us some more details saying
that the UI is going to be 25 larger
which is optimization for touch and the
apps will still be iPad OS apps and not
Mac OS apps so they're basically giving
you a tease of Mac OS that works better
but it's still mostly iPad OS and if you
want some credibility for this league
imagine Booth said that the source is
the same one that leaked Apple mixer
back in the past and it turned out to be
real and if you want to know what I'm
talking about way back on March 15 2022
he said apple is developing a smart
system for iPad OS codenamed Apple mixer
where your screen would automatically
shrink when connected to the keyboard
and trackpad and he had this example
footage right right here and guess what
that is stage manager that's exactly
what came out so he was correct and his
Source was correct as well so that's why
I believe the simplified Mac OS for the
iPad Pro leak is real and that's why I
believe we're going to be getting that
new hybrid device where we're going to
get a new iPad Pro with probably a new
magic keyboard and those will be
required to get this Mac OS like UI so
apple is going to sell a whole lot more
iPad pros and Magic keyboards but here's
the final issue even though I think the
iPad Pro with Mac OS like UI is coming
mark German did specifically say that
they're working on a new Macbook Pro
with a touch screen for release in 2025
so maybe that is still gonna happen
legitimately on the MacBook Pro but I
guess we're gonna have to wait and see
how the leaks pan out now if you
completely disagree with my thoughts on
the whole iPad Pro with Mac OS thing let
me know down in the comment section
below but if you want to see my
suggestion for which MacBook you should
buy right now check out the YouTube
product tagging feature and click the
circle button to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]